hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the shaving again a
variation in the Sicilian offense
Sicilian being one of the more popular
defenses in all of chess pawn to e4 and
then pawn to c5 very aggressive defense
from black Black has one of the highest
win percentages playing pawn to c5 and
there's a lot of variations that black
can go into and many people will always
ask for me to make videos on different
patients so we're gonna go over one of
the more popular ones to shave it again
there's a lot of ways to get to this
particular variation but Knight to f3
pawn d6 pawn d4 this is just the main
line after the pawn takes Knight to d4
Knight to f6 and the Knight to c3 pretty
common throughout now black has many
different variations that you can go
through from here pawn to a6 the knight
door if that's the most popular but we
do have the option of pawns who e6
popularized by characters prof he's
played this in many top tournaments that
we've covered on this channel as well
but it's a very solid defense from black
controls both of the d5 and the e5
squares it's a lot of flexibility to has
not committed to anything or something
like pawn to e5 all of a sudden doesn't
have as much control over the light
square so something like Bishop to c4 is
more dangerous although black has a lot
of good options where pawn to e6 okay
Bishop to c4 doesn't mean as much
because black can can block the entire
diagonal right here so you need to see
that the flexibility that it does have
but you can also see it's not as
aggressive not controlling any of the
fourth-ranked at all so just really
waiting to see what white does now why
it does have multiple options can be
extremely aggressive which we'll go over
and can play a slower game and say okay
if you're gonna wait I'm gonna wait as
well and see how you're gonna develop
and then continue from there so we're
gonna go over the main line some of the
things that I think about if I'm playing
as White's how I like to attack black
and then if you're from blacks point of
view how you're going to continue to
attack if you're playing this is Cillian
if
like you're usually trying to attack and
then how you approach some of the
variations that white can play the most
aggressive line that white can take and
you can probably guess this is my
recommendation because I like to be
extremely aggressive when I play chess I
just think it's more fun that way is
pawn to g4 and there's a few reasons why
this is such a good move first thing is
if blacks not going to be aggressive and
push pieces forward then white needs to
take advantage of that and push as much
as possible also the pawn on e6 is
blocking this LightSquared Bishop on c8
so this does pretty much let this pawn
here on g4 stay here for free yes the
Knights attacking it but it's being
defended by the Queen here on d1 this is
also preparing for the pond to push
forward here on g5 which is going to
force the minor piece here on f6 to move
it's not really gonna go to a great
school you can see there's limited
options as far as where the knight can
go
he's usually gonna come back to a non
solid square that would be an extremely
good thing for white also in the
Sicilian offense black is not usually
looking to castle on the Queen side
because like has given up that pawn on
the C file so just a lot of exposure on
the Queen side no protection at all so
white all of a sudden says yeah I'm just
gonna throw everything I can at the King
side of the board because that's really
where black would like to attack now
black has some options if he sees this
one of the things that you may see from
black is pawn to h6 there's one of the
more common moves to stop the pawn
coming up here to g5 here I just
recommend pawn to h4 it continuously
pushes on the King side puts as much
pressure as possible for black now black
can't play something like pawn to g5
because the pawn can freely take
attacking the knight right here the pawn
can't recapture because the rook can
come down here to h8 so a lot of
mistakes that black can get into so how
do they can
and you if they're not going to play
pawn to g5 one of the things that you
could see is pawn to e5 attacking the
knight right here then just gonna play
Knight to f5 this makes a lot of sense
continuously being aggressive on the
Kings side of the board
if black wants to push the night away
say pawn to g6 y can actually take the
pawn here on h6 now it doesn't look like
it right away but we'll go over why you
can and right away if the bishop
recaptures then just pawn to g5 and you
can probably see right here that White's
gonna gain back material let's say the
bishop comes to g7 then the pawn takes
the bishop is going to recapture and now
the pawn to h5 this is extremely good
you have the Queen here on d1 defending
this you also have the rook here on h1
everything is attacking the king's head
the board
y can still castle on the Queen side
have good protection for his King this
is gonna be extremely good later on the
knight can come down here to d5 a great
outpost for the white knight all things
are lookin extremely good for white and
you can you can tell from this who is
the aggressor in the game it's white
usually if someone plays this Sicilian
defense is black they want to be the
aggressor why it's completely taken that
off the table they're the one pushing
the action on the King side of the board
if we come back a few moves instead of
pawn to e5 another move that we could
see after pawn to h4 is Knight to c6 a
I'm just not gonna worry about what you
have going on over here in this case I
would recommend rook to g1 the critical
square is going to be pawn to g5 have
both the bishop from c1 defending that
so just swing over the rook here on g1
is going to be the recommendation don't
even worry about the knight over here on
c6 if your opponent wants to play the
game on the Queen side that's fine if
they take ya you're just gonna have
another attacker coming down with your
Queen to d4 that is going to be fine
never come back and say instead of the
pawns
you aged six what if they try something
completely different so you play pawn to
g4 and then they play pawn to e5 say I'm
gonna go ahead and tack this Knights
right here now there's a couple options
I'll go over why I recommend what I do
because you could play Knight to f5
right away and this is a extremely good
move it's a great outpost for this
Knight but you can see that this Bishop
can go ahead and take this right away
and really black is looking to start to
trade material because they they can
sense the fact that White's putting a
lot of pressure and as soon as they can
alleviate that pressure the pawn
structure for whites not that good so
this would be a good exchange for black
so because of that we want the night to
come here to f5 first we're going to an
in-between move and that is Bishop to b5
yes there it's hacking the night here on
d4 but they're in check so they have to
do something now there's a couple
options that they have let's say they
play Bishop to d7 okay well we can just
exchange right here after the Knight
takes now we can come to f5 much better
position black can no longer take that
and instead if they don't bring the
bishop here let's say they brought the
Knight to d7 okay well don't even have
to do anything right now could go ahead
and play Knight to f5 putting a lot of
pressure on the King side and black
cannot force the night away so those are
some of the options that you'll see once
you play the pawn to g4 now that was an
extremely aggressive move from white to
play pawn to g4 and so a lot of players
as black they don't like to play this
opening because of what happens if they
play pawn to g4 so that's why the knight
Dorf is one of the more popular moves
upon day six just waits to see what
their opponent's going to do and so pawn
to d4 not as good in this position but
we'll go ahead and look at some other
variations boats you can see what it
would play as black and then if you want
to play some other variations as white
you can as well the first one is we have
the classical variation with bishop here
to e2 Karpov used to play this quite a
bit
usually Bishop to e2 just means you're
cancelling on the King side for safety
that's not necessarily what this is
looking to do white still wants to be
extremely aggressive so even if white
castles on the Kings side this Bishop is
really eyeing down this h5 Square and
wants to be pretty aggressive both of
these bishops eyeing down on the King
side so maybe from here
Bishop to e7 castle on the King side
castle and then pawn to f4 now white can
play a little quieter but I always
recommend to be extremely aggressive so
f4 is the play white still has a good
defense but this does open up the door
for the rook to play a more pivotal role
similar to what you see in the Kings
gambit game if you come back and say
instead of Bishop here to e7 maybe pawn
to e5 okay well this is going to be
similar to before the knight would like
to come to f5 but the bishop here on c8
is eyeing down at that square here on f5
so we still have the same in-between
move as before Bishop to b5 if you look
at this that you have but the bishop has
already moved twice and you don't want
to move the same minor piece over and
over it unless there's a good reason
keep in mind your opponent is move their
pawn twice they so they came to e6 and
then e five so you don't have to worry
too much about moving your Bishop is
sort of a waiting game this Bishop here
to e2 seeing where your opponent's gonna
do they they blinked first okay they
came to e5 now you can come down to b5
same thing as before if they play Bishop
down to d7 you can go ahead and take
with your Bishop and then Knights great
Knight can come down to f5 if instead
they say I'm gonna bring my Knights here
to d7 night down to f5 and if they try
to get this Bishop off because many
times pawn to a6 it's a common move in
the Sicilian defense all together but
now forcing the Bishop to move go ahead
and take with your Bishop because this
Knights can freely take here because it
has a defender on d1 and what that means
is you really are forcing your opponents
to take with their queen they don't want
to because this blocks off the light
square development for their Bishop but
if they take with their Bishop that
Knight can freely take here on d6 the
bishop can't capture because the Queen
here
on D one can to thin that so just more
opportunities for your opponents to make
a mistake and then then I could always
come down here to b7 take another pawn
why it's gonna be in a very good
position so these are some of the things
you'll see in the classical variation a
few other things that you will see or
may want to try out yourself the first
one is the English attack and that is
Bishop to e3 now any time you seen an
opening your opponent is getting their
dark square Bishop for white outside
before they're light square bishop that
generally means they're looking to
castle on the Queen side of the board
especially in the Sicilian offense
knowing that black wants to castle on
the Kings side when your opponent
castles on the Queen side they're gonna
be throwing everything in the kitchen
sink at the king side so just be aware
of what white is trying to do usually
the Queen's gonna be coming next maybe
Queen to d2 castle on the Queen side of
the board so be aware of how you're
going to play knowing that that move is
coming not as popular but sometimes you
will see that English attack and then
lastly you're gonna have the Fischer
attack some people like to play the
bishop down here to c4 what's nice from
blacks point of view is it's easier to
to fin usually the bishop here on c4 is
attacking the pawn on f7 and the only
piece defending that is the king but the
pawn here on e6 is blocking this defense
it does not have to worry about it as
much so those are some of the main lines
that you will see the classical
variation and the carriers attack with
that pawn to g4 are the more popular
ones but wanted to give everyone an
overview of the shavin egan variation in
the Sicilian offense hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video looking to make more
variations in this is an offense and
then also some of the other more popular
openings out there if you have other
requests you can always email those to
me that's the best way to let me know of
other videos you're looking for me to
make and that is the chess website at
gmail.com thanks so much for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video